because the Jews recognized that the
monotheism that the prophet brought was
unprecedented he was the greatest
monotheist who ever lived they
recognized that I mean what he did was
more than all of their prophets put
together right just what the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam did
how successful of a monotheist he was
they recognize that there's something
special about him so some of them will
say he's a goel goel means that he's a
renewer of of monotheism he was a great
man others say no he was a true Prophet
but he was only sent to uh the
like the non-jews the Gentiles and
others they say no he sent to all of us
and they converted to Islam so there's
there's always been a type of mutual
respect between Jews and Muslims now
this the the present conflict has skewed
a lot of perceptions and that's
unfortunate